on this episode I took about a bunch of
stuff I gotta go fast enjoy you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
askgaryvee show
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 95 of
the ask gary vee show super exciting to
be here on a Friday
it's beautiful day in New York City
played basketball yesterday Stefan and
Dirac teamed up to make the video
where is
linked in facebook end in YouTube by the
way Facebook peeps you just saw the
share button call-to-action before the
show I am obsessed with the amount of
people watching versus the amount of
people sharing I do not like the quant
data behind it I feel that you should
love me more and share it more so share
it that was also for everybody else
who's watching on any platform besides
Facebook or listening yes go home find
it on Facebook and share it that's right
that's what you call a right mother
India let's get into the show Jose says
stuck at DMV New Jersey sucks here what
can they do to bring themselves into
this decade online and off so antiquated
Jose there's nothing they can do and let
me explain why there's nothing they can
do because I think I'm not even educated
in this they are run by the state which
would make sense which means it's
political it's all the things that I do
not believe in and they won't fix it the
only way that the MDS can be fixed is if
they go private and are run by
entrepreneurs who then actually care
about the customer and will fire
somebody if they suck at the DMV like
everybody I've ever had and care about
efficiency and time and speed and
getting people out and and do things
like bring in Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts
into the DMV to make more money on the
rent or the arbitrage of making a
percentage of each sale you know
innovate and care and give a crap all
the things that government industries
and and objects don't do because it is
not in their best vested interest
because the people that can't innovate
and can't win in a competitive landscape
they default into doing those things
instead how's that for some fire it
pisses me off it's so crazy and I don't
want to be a hardcore like honestly I
don't want to be a hardcore capitalist
on this issue and I know that was a
hardcore to that side as of an answer I
ever forgive because I do think I blend
but like I don't know like if you don't
incentivize humans in some way
to do the right thing you can't win and
more and more in a digital world and
this is where I would say I'm more
passionate and more hardcore about my
points of view on government agencies
and school today than I even was 10
years ago because there's alternatives
like I'm a pragmatic kind of dude and I
understood that like you know some of
the things but now there's so much
innovation there's so many ways we can
solve it just we're not incentivized
these are bigger issues than you and I
and so privatizing is the way I think
those would be better I really do and
look privatizing has its own bad stuff
I'm not one of these like everything
should go that route because I you know
I believe but but in a way in the same
way that I believe unions were really
valuable when the Titans of the first
you know by the way I could see unions
coming back as an important thing as we
live through this second Industrial
Revolution but for right now while we're
alive take advantage of these
opportunities Anthony says I recently
learned about Facebook dark post yeah I
know I'm a little late but there is tons
of info about dark post on YouTube there
are also people selling dark post
courses would you pay for a course or
use all the free info on YouTube Anthony
I would not pay for a course I would use
all the free information on YouTube and
other places I'm sure there's a ton of
white papers and slide shares and if you
use that thing called Google you can
find more stuff dark posts are not that
complicated because you just need the
usage of dark posts is not that
complicated
it's dribbling and shooting a basketball
complicated no is using a screwdriver
complicated no you can learn those
things being great at them is a whole
different thing you know the way to be
successful in dark posts on Facebook is
to understand the psychology and
salesmanship it takes to create a
narrative to the end consumer that you
target that predicates an action for
them to purchase something that you want
to happen that's hard that's hard that's
analyzing data interpreting it then
deploying it with creative call to
actions that are the variable of the
success to it against the right demo at
the right time and the right vehicle
around the right
ecology that's hard understanding how to
make an ad happen on Facebook is not
hard everybody can do that that should
take you 20 minutes to hours or four
hours depending on how you learn to
figure that out
it's are you good enough to then make it
happen so no do not pay for a course
because you know you'll get that
information for free what you should do
is get educated on being great at the
bigger picture at hand which is the
craft of the usage of the tool not the
tool itself dr. Laurie asked do you ever
have dreams at night about your business
dr. Laurie I think I've had way too I
mean I dream about business all the time
I mean I think you know even though like
I go to sleep and I'm like okay dream
about jet Superbowl and I'm like a
2-second so I'm like in a meeting with
stunwin you know not as much as I am
Hydra I mean I dream about business all
the time and then then I dream about all
sorts of stuff but I don't recall most
of my dreams I'm not sure what
percentage of dreams I can work on well
there's something to be your dreams do
you think you recall steam India Devon
d-roc yeah by the way I think all four
numbers are grossly high I think if you
net-net the game out I bet you it's like
point zero zero so it's I mean if you
think about how many dreams you probably
have in tonight oh I bet you there's
Google it up somebody real quick I make
sure the numbers insane and then if you
think about how many nights you sleep
you know all of them I think it can be
far far are pressed to get to 25% what's
what's your first Google result right
he's a dreamer folks lorg asks how can
the communications manager of a
non-profit on a heavy topic such as
human trafficking make the depressing
content dynamic
for I think the first thing you need to
do is make sure that you realize the
content doesn't have to be dynamic right
I think you know everybody thinks like
how do we make it social how do we make
it fun like certain content has to be
done a certain way it's contextual like
I mean this is really hardcore stuff
that you're dealing with I actually
think the content needs to be
educational while not being too
complicated I mean it's a depressing
manner you're not gonna be able to light
it up right you need to focus on what it
is and so I would I would educate and
create narratives through white papers
infographics slideshares videos pictures
quote cards that that actually educate
the market none of us here none of us
here and when I say here I mean everyone
listening and watching I would I would I
would argue that less than 1% of us are
really educated on the matter so how do
you get the information out and I don't
think that it needs to be dynamic I
think it needs to be truthful and it
needs to be contextual to the platform
is that a 45 second video on YouTube
with the right tone music behind it that
is giving me the information is that an
infographic with the right color tones
that aren't bright orange and yeah you
know I don't think bright orange and
yellow and sparklers on my Pinterest
board around the subject matter and so I
think I think respecting subject matter
and making a contextual for the platform
are way more important than pigeonholing
yourself in a world where you see other
people having the option to be dynamic
in a social media world and you wanting
to be in that world because either you
want to be there or to you think that's
the way to win I think the best way to
respect the content is to respect the
content and and I think that matters
Thomas asks would you be willing to
sacrifice your ethics core business win
Thomas's great question as you know it's
because of the askgaryvee show and how
busy I've been
I haven't been answering a lot of the
askgaryvee if any of the askgaryvee
questions as they come through my
Twitter feed but I answered that one
pretty damn quick India
give me the call on how fast I responded
to that in minutes or days less than a
couple minutes good so uh and the answer
was a big fat no and by the way I'm
gonna break this down into
in place so it's not only no because I
want to live a noble life and be a good
dude and like ethics matter to me and my
legacy I think everybody who knows me
knows my legacy mabh cest with my legacy
over the currency and and so that that
would be that factor but it's also
because I actually think it's
practically the right thing like I'm a
big fan right of like the slower hedged
money like I I just I feel like I make
more money if I don't grasp it the money
that's in front of me and so one of the
biggest reasons I won't break my ethics
is if I do break my ethics the people
that I'm building around me would see
that you know my assistants see
everything that I do
they've complete @cv access to money in
Bucks Steve has full access to my inbox
if he sees that II know it's hard to do
anything now but not documented if I
knew something that breaks you know at
this point he has a good sense of what
my morals are and how I roll he would if
he saw me do something even if it didn't
have anything to do with his world or
the stuff that we do together that
breaks that compass he would then have
to question everything that I've
established with him as a moral compass
which would then lose the trust that we
have which you then slow us down in all
the speed that I value the most its
speed the fact that this whole team here
and this whole collective team here and
you as a team here don't have to once
you get to know me once I can get over
that hump don't have to then question
anything for like a moral or emotional
standpoint it adds to the speed of
everything that's what a great culture
is its speed you're not spending the 15
minutes a day bickering you're not
spending the four hours a day wondering
if that person is trying to ruin you you
know you're not you're not doing those
things which then lets you go fast and
fast fast my friends is the oxygen of
winning the big fast important game see
it's even a game called fast you have to
be fast so for me it's really it's
really important that everything breaks
the second I make that kind of decision
and there's just not enough money I mean
I guess there's enough money everybody
has a price a trillion you know truly
would feel that and you know what's even
funny it's funny even if that came out
of my mouth I don't know I I don't know
I'm gonna end up I'm gonna end up leave
a lot of money on the table in my life
because that's not the way I score
myself I score myself on number amount
of people the matrix of the number
amount of people that come to my funeral
and the business success that I was able
to create you know I'd be lying if it
was just about everybody showing up to
my funeral but then I was like didn't
win in this game that I play scored in
business growth dollars all the things
the game but a hefty push to to that
funeral number you know again recently
unfortunately in the tech space we had a
beloved character pass away CEO of
SurveyMonkey that a lot of people know a
lot of my friends knew really well I
didn't really know him well but it was
interesting how I was affected by it
just watching the outpouring of what
kind of a mensch what kind of a great
human being he was you know I'd be lying
if I didn't say wow that's a little bit
of a preview of what I want at scale as
well and so I just got there I don't you
know it's funny I literally set a
trillion and I'm taking it back
there's just I just can't go there it's
just just not the way I want people
talking about me yeah cool question of
the day what percentage of Dreams do you
recall you give asking questions I'll
keep answering them